having this kind of system helps improve
the goals of peace in the fields a
little bit more harmony and labor
relations to have an early way for a
union to be recognized what you knew
what is that too hard to get in orderly
way in which workers can decide they
don't want to have union representation
after decades of failure to unionize
California's farm workers this massive
grape strike in Delano California
finally pressured the industry to accept
contracts with the United Farm Workers
Union and it was this man says our
Shabbos who became the face of the
farmworkers movement a revered figure
with roads schools and even holidays
named after him
I'm angry that I live in the world or a
man who cooks food can feed a family but
with time some things have changed I
never like a company where they have
union I don't see it that I need to pay
somebody to to explain me my rights
at its peak the powerful ufw claimed
50,000 dues paying members now it has
fewer than 5,000 yet even with
unionization on the decline wages and
benefits have actually improved this has
led to an unusual situation in the
Central Valley where workers at one farm
have banded together to protest not
their employer but the Union in our case
I don't see that we need it because we
get the highest peace and we in our
condition of work is the best I could
say karaman farms is one of the largest
tree fruit producers in the country and
employs more than 10,000 workers a year
that's more than double the entire
membership of the UFW
they also claim to pay more than the
industry average and point to County
employment statistics to back it up my
name is Dan growlin I'm a co-owner of
growing farming I grew up in the
industry I haven't missed a season since
I was 11 years old 23 years ago there
was first one election
there was no clear winner so there was a
runoff election and ufw won that
election we had one bargaining session
yeah 20 years ago and then they
disappeared the Union hasn't collected
dues or bargained on behalf of Grauman's
workers for more than two decades but
still claims it's been the certified
representative of the workers this
entire time the contract they demand be
implemented immediately requires three
percent of wages to be paid as dues to
the Union and calls on growlin to
terminate any employee who refuses to
pay up this plan did not sit well with
many of the workers main problem is an
Al Arabi office because there is
supposed to be no neutral with us and
they're not we can see that they're
supporting ufw organization the AL RB
has proven that they do not have the
employees best interest in mind if they
did then they would allow the employees
to choose workers from growlin farms
came to you with a petition full of
signatures asking for a vote
administered by al RB to decertify the
union you rejected that petition why did
you do that in this case we needed to
have a majority showing there were some
serious problems with signatures
submitted that turned out to be
fraudulent Sylvia and I we would go
before work middle lunch we didn't get
our lunch sometimes because we had to
collect the signatures and then after
work so it was constant constant we
dealt with it constantly and for them to
say it's fake it's not fair but Sylvia
was determined she and her daughter
collected thousands more signatures and
submitted a second petition this time al
RB offered a different reason for
rejecting them if employers get involved
in telling workers to sign a petition if
employers are you know instigating
supporting and then what the law says is
that this petition really isn't a
measure of true worker support the Union
has accused growlin of unfair labor
practices saying management promoted
anti-union petitions and sent out
anti-union messages in response growl
Ann invited al RB invest
Gators onto the property to oversee the
petition process and instruct workers
that they have a legal right to unionize
management is not forcing us to do this
it makes me feel sad sometimes because
they think that we're not smart enough
to know our rights and we know
everyone's often what our employees tell
us is they don't trust the LRB
they feel coerced by the LRV they have
told they have cited Silas Shaw or
himself as someone they don't trust the
workers staged a protest gathering
outside growl and farms and the AL RB
offices to demand a vote mirroring the
famous grape strike some workers even
trekked to the state's capital to
deliver their demand for decertification
to Governor Jerry Brown the same
governor who created the ALR be 38 years
ago finally the AL RB relented and
allowed an election do you see any
problem with the fact that you were both
administering the election and
investigating claims against the company
at the same time it's a very open
process
I had communication throughout the day
with attorneys for the company for the
petitioner my position I'm with the the
general counsel in terms of prosecuting
unfair labor practices our job is to
we're really a law enforcement is there
any conflict there having the single
agency both be the prosecutor and the
judge well we have really tight controls
in terms of my ability to communicate
with the board and there's an objection
process that goes directly to the boards
so if someone has a complaint about how
a lr be administered the election they
can take it to the ALR it be board right
exactly
because the board is not involved
directly in administering the elections
after countless hours spent gathering
signatures filing paperwork and getting
out the vote
Rowan's workers finally got their life
the result we don't know what does that
mean to have an election and not count
the votes so where's the right for the
farmworkers
where is it the only thing I could say
to the LRB is to actually respect us I
am American citizen and I believe my
vote should be counted are the ballots
being impounded here at in this building
yes they're in a safe what needs to
happen for you to crack open that safe
and count those ballots the board has to
make that decision and what they've said
is that there needs to be a hearing
first done on certain complaints and
issues around the supervisor involvement
is there any kind of timeline on that
there hasn't been a timeline that set
the soon as they resolve this situation
it's gonna be that our environment and
the work is gonna be like before it was
because this is very important for me
because my family works here if Cesar
were here today he certainly wouldn't be
supporting what's being done now which
is a union trying to impose itself on
employees a union that basically has
done nothing for them for 20 years comes
back and says give us three percent of
your wages or we're gonna require that
you be fired that doesn't fit within
Cesar's values